Thank you so much for taking time out of your day today to help share your experience with everyone that says, yeah, yeah. So, how are you doing today?
Doing good. Doing good. Good.
Back in 2013, I had a rare tumor in my eye and a friend of mine, new Dr. Connors, as she said, share your go get a second opinion.
What's it going to hurt? And that's when he was up in White Bear Lake, Minnesota, and I got there. So I called and they said, Oh, yes, we have opening and Monday, come on in and check it out.
So I go in. He did a lot of muscle testing and he told me what he found was the root cause. And I went, Oh, interesting, right?
And that was kind of the first time I really had somebody do major muscle testing on me, too.
And he goes, we have this device here called the rife and he said that I could come in every week or every day that week.
And take care of the tumor. And I went, OK, right? What do I got to lose? Right?
Because I mean, I was 70% blind in the eye. And the medical doctor said that I wasn't going to get my vision back.
Oh, and scary.
OK, that was Monday. I was in there, started the treatment, came back to say Wednesday, Thursday and Friday.
By Friday, I had full vision in my eye.
Wow. So four sessions with the rife machine, how long was the session?
It was there eight hours. Oh, OK, you did. OK, it was all day thing. OK.
And so by Friday, it was totally gone, totally gone.
And I had an appointment with the eye doctor the following week.
So I went back there and, you know, they scan the eye and I didn't see any boop or any bump in the scan.
And I went, it's gone. It's totally gone, right?
He comes in and he goes, what did you do? I know you had a tumor in your eye. What did you do? Oh, gosh.
And I told him that I used the rife and he got so mad. He was like, well, you're in remission and it'll come back.
And I want you back here in two weeks to do another scan. So I went back in two weeks.
It was still gone and at that time, I had got the rife and I started using it at night because the root cause, I needed to address.
And that was one of the things that I really appreciated about Dr. Connors.
It wasn't just what was physically happening. It was the root cause.
And I don't know if you ever heard of H. Pylori, the H. Pylori was the root cause.
And it took, I don't want to say a couple of years, but because I go in and get muscle tested and nope, still there. And he helped with mushrooms and different things like that.
Yeah, I was going to ask if he recommended some supplements to and test it for those.
Oh, yes.
And so it was, it was a process and I remember coming in and I thought, okay, today's going to, you know, finally be that day, right?
And sure enough, it was, it was like a heat, I just tested clean on everything.
And it's like, don't you, you're good. It's gone. It's, you know, and so it's like, yay, right?
Oh, yeah.
And his guidance on all this stuff and like I said, getting to the root and going after that and did really amazing.
And recently within the last couple of years, I've been having, I don't know, more health issues.
And this last week, I was diagnosed with something very rare again.
And I reached out to Dr. Connors, I sent him with the doctor, medical doctors, that said.
And they got me in a consult the next day and he said, all right, yep, some new programs for the rife.
And he goes, the rife would be the best defense for what I'm dealing with.
And I thought, wow, thank you, Lord, that I have this device.
And so he wrote up new programs for me, set them out, I'm already running them.
So we got to do some blood work, get to get some blood work done.
And some of these rare things again, right?
And it's like, okay, but I do believe one of the things is the Lord leads my past in my direction.
And I really believe that Dr. Connors is such a blessing to God's people, because I wouldn't have my eye right now, I'll tell you that.
And I probably wouldn't have my other eye either, having Dr. Connors help me with these health issues, even though they were what the medical term was, it wasn't the root cause.
And going after that root cause, and now with this new diagnosis, and, you know, it's been 10 years, right, almost 10 years.
And so I never thought, you know, would I invested and initially became, you know, Dr. Connors patient, I said, oh, this is a one and done thing, right?
And now 10 years later, here I am again, and it's like, yeah, I'm glad, you know, you bring up a good point that you seek out for what's going on at the time, but little do you know, without a crystal ball into the future or without knowing that whatever comes along in your life and whatever other challenges you might face with your health.
He, you know, you consult with him, and he lets you know, okay, here's what we can do, here's what we can try, here are some options, and no matter what it is.
So I love that you've kept in touch with Connors Clinic, and that you think of Dr. Connors and Connors Clinic when something comes up with your health to see if there's anything that we can do to help guide you in whatever comes along.
So yeah, and actually before this diagnosis, I was doing that prolonged, I get the prolonged fasting diet from you guys, I love that absolutely love it, and I've been doing that for a couple of years and recommending it to my friends too, because it's just it's a good cleansing diet.
And one of the things I really appreciate about Dr. Connors so is he makes sure what he sells or what he recommends is a good product.
He just doesn't put a product out, and one of my bracelets, you know, because when I was looking at EMF stuff, I went, I wonder if Dr. Connors did research.
I went out to your website, and sure enough, I said, oh, great, I'll get it, right?
So it was nice to know that this resource is there, and it was really interesting.
He sent me about six months ago, because I've been dealing with hard issues.
He sent me a link to the doctor talks that the seminars that these functional doctors are now doing.
Yeah.
And they're sharing stuff and getting the word out, hey guys, we can go after this root cause and actually help these people, right?
So I took a heart clinic or a heart seminar with Dr. Conn, which is a cardiologist out in Michigan.
And I learned and I cleaned so much good information.
It's just the knowledge that Dr. Connors has about health and wellness and everything is just, it's, I'm so appreciative.
I cannot thank him enough. He's a blessing beyond.
And I'm so blessed that the Lord had me go see him 10 years ago and still today, he's still my doctor, right?
Yeah, yeah, all that's so great. That's great to hear.
And we appreciate you and we appreciate all your prayers for Dr. Connors and our clinic and our mission to just help empower people with their health.
And like you said, help get to finding the root cause because just putting a band aid on it isn't taking care of the problem.
It's maybe masking a symptom, but right.
I'm so thrilled for you and thrilled that that Dr. Connors is doing this work and still doing this work after so many years.
And we get to work with fantastic people like you.
Last year, a good friend of mine, she was diagnosed with cancer.
And I, and this was her second round of cancer. And I thought, oh, please, I just wish you'd go see Dr. Connors.
And she had put out there that she was going to go to a natural functional medicine doctor and I went, hmm, I wonder who that is, right?
And I went over there to bring some food and I says, you know, I don't want to ask, but, you know, I really have this doctor that I would really recommend.
And she goes, no, she goes, I really feel good with this doctor that I'm seeing.
And I said, can I ask his name, who are you seeing? And she said, Dr. Connors.
And I went, yes.
And, you know, and she's doing great.
I know last year she had a test, whatever one of the spots was totally gone.
She said, so I know when I seen her a couple weeks ago, she looked fabulous.
I'm so worried, right? And what, I feel what the enemy meant for evil.
God's going to turn it around for his good. And I really do believe that's part of Dr Connors' vision is to equip us with some of the gifts that the God has given us to use to heal our bodies.
That's right. That's right.
So many God-given resources that we can use, yeah,
So, I would not hesitate to recommend Dr. Conner's to anyone, he is a spin of blessing to me, I can't think him enough.
Well, thank you. Thank you again. And again, God bless you. I'm so, so grateful for you and for your time and for you sharing your story and we really appreciate you.
Thank you. Thank you. I hope that God continues to bless you and take care of you and we'll keep praying for you.
Thank you. Bye bye. Bye bye.